على صعيد اخر لايق الاهميه بل ويزيد من
تعقيدات واقع حكومه نتنياهو اضافه ثالثه
محتملات تسوقها عمليات استهداف وقتل
القوات الاسرائيليه المتزايده بحق
الفلسطينيين والرد عليها في الضفه الغربيه
والقدس والخشيه من دخول غزه على خط
المواجهه وامام الخوف من اتساع رقعه
الاضطراب خاصه بعد عمليه اطلاق النار في
شارع ديزنجو في تل ابيب طلب قاده
اسرائيليون نتنياهو بعزل وزير الامن
الداخلي اطمار بنكفير محضرين من انه يسعى
الى تفجير انتفاضه ثالثه من خلال اصراره
على هدم المنازل الفلسطينيين خلال شهر
رمضان خمسه قاده سابقين وثلاثه وثلاثون من
كبار مسؤول الشرطه السابقين وقعوا على
الرساله التحذيريه الموقف نفسه عبر عنه
قائد شرطه القدس المتقاعديه ايريا اير
اسحاق من ان بنكفير الذي يعتبر من ابرز
داعمي حركه الاستيطان في القدس الشرقيه
والضفه الغربيه قد يشعل انتفاضه
ان وق عت ستحول اسرائيل الى دوله منبوذه
بحسبها خاصه وانه هو من تسبب باتفاضه مايو
2021 التي طالت مدن الخط الاخضر ونتجت
عنها مواجهات في مدن وبلدات عده